all right the first topic we're going to
talk about is the collapse in
institutional trust uh which i think for
people inside of bitcoin crypto uh kind
of the decentralized world individual
sovereignty uh they're interested in
those ideas
this is like duh right of course there's
a collapse of institutional trust people
who maybe are just new to this stuff uh
or who are listening to this for the
first time this may actually be shocking
to them so walk me through how you think
about that
falling amount of trust and is there
like a quantifiable metric that you look
at or is it more so just sentiment and
kind of anecdotal evidence
well i i think this is obviously
subjective but um
uh a16z andrews and horowitz put
together a
a web 3 policy team that's been doing a
lot of work in dc trying to educate
policy makers um what crypto is uh
broadly what what web 3 is that you know
there's been a little bit of an attempt
to rebrand crypto as web 3 because it's
a little bit more friendly of a term
less scary and it's
i think more reflective of the fact that
we are trying to rebuild you know the
entire internet not just
cryptocurrencies
um but in their uh education document
and presentation of policymakers they
have this really
amazing graphic that is
a chart on two axes based on competence
and trust so
low trust high trust
you know high confidence low competence
and um and this was based on survey
results from edelman
um big market research firm that uh
basically showed
no
modern institution is seen as both high
trust
and high competence right so um ngos uh
like you know nonprofits were considered
um high trust but that's not necessarily
high confidence businesses were
considered
um high competence but you know lower on
the trust uh
axis and then you had um the mainstream
media and the government so basically
you know the the uh the three branches
the government and then the fourth
estate the media um as ranking uh very
negatively in both competence and trust
um and
when you're living in an environment
like that and you see everything that
we've seen over the last couple of years
that you know folks in your audience or
i'm sure have heard you know
relentlessly um 40 of dollars you know
printed in the last 18 months um you
know we've mismanaged covid the
afghanistan exit was a a disaster you're
seeing you know progressively more you
know censorship platforming
there's just um i think this bubbling
sentiment that a system that we've built
um
are slowly disintegrating and really
there's there's kind of an absence of
leadership
and i think um it took a while even for
me because i got into you know bitcoin
back in 2013 and even back then it kind
of felt like a pessimistic bet on the
future but over the last few years you
started to realize that like bitcoin and
crypto powered networks might actually
be the only quote unquote institution
that could fit in that you know upper
right hand quadrant that's both high
trust thanks to encryption and high
competence because you have the best
most talented people in the world that
are flooding into this space at you know
an alarming rate and um and building
things that people are actually using
now so
um
i think uh you know
the framing is
you know you're not gonna be excited
about crypto if your life is perfect and
uh you think that everything is going
just swimmingly and you're one of the
you know like 11 of people that think
congress is doing a good job um but for
everybody else um there's kind of this
like simmering
uh unrest uh for for the last several
years it really got thrown into high
gear thanks to kovid and um
and it's it's kind of brought a lot of
uh the problems with our existing
institutions into focus
the question now is which ones do we
slowly replace with you know
decentralized math-based systems um
using crypto versus um which ones are
actually gonna
you know maintain credibility and and
survive this transformation so in the
document you explicitly call out the
difference between mercenaries and
missionaries and you basically say you
know whether you're here as a missionary
or a mercenary you'll find that one of
the primary unifying forces behind this
movement is the belief that
decentralized technologies with embedded
financial incentives offer a compelling
often lucrative alternative to our
decaying legacy institutions which first
of all is just like a pro level sentence
that you put together there uh but this
idea of both mercenary and missionary
both finding kind of a home or value in
this can you talk a little bit about the
difference between those two groups of
people coming together around one common
set of technologies
um
you know i'll i'll paraphrase a number
of of smart people that have uh that
have said this but
yeah crypto is a um a new tech paradigm
dressed as a ponzi scheme right
something along those lines and
the reason that bitcoin and these other
systems have taken off is because you
know they've been bootstrapped into
existence by speculators um folks that
believe in this vision of the future
that
ultimately are you're going to be
rewarded for their early faith even if
it does take a while for
mainstream adoption to take root right
so perfect example is bitcoin
um until the the infamous you know
bitcoin pizza transaction which you know
in hindsight is hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of bitcoin right
um
without that transaction
you don't have
the
um
the first you know proof of concept that
you could actually buy something real uh
with bitcoin right it's it's i think the
same you know with with many of these
other you know emerging assets like
without the first icos on ethereum you
couldn't prove
that um ether would be a reserve
currency for all types of decentralized
finance applications
um without you know the the crypto punks
you know airdrop and some of these games
um that have emerged you know as far
back as 2017 you wouldn't have been able
to prove that you know non-fungible
tokens are nfts
could be these really interesting you
know scarce digital objects with with
different historical attributes
so um i think the missionaries are the
ones that see this get excited and then
you know build and stick around for the
long term whether it's a bear market
where they're you know kind of in the
trenches building for the next cycle
um
or the mercenaries that you know quite
frankly are just
uh at worst necessary evils
but at best you know they're they're the
backstops of the entire
new financial system right without the
speculators without these you know deep
pocketed individuals you don't have um
liquid markets and and you certainly
don't have the market cap that we have
today
that can attract the type of new inflows
that we're seeing that's going to fund
new applications and new infrastructure
and you know kind of continue the upward
momentum of the rest of the industry so
i think
um
it's uh it's it's crazy
with uh crypto how compressed these pipe
cycles are if you think about like the
classic you know peak of inflated
expectations and then the long trough of
disillusionment and and then you know
kind of the gradual upslope in the
installation phase we've seen like six
or seventies in in crypto over the last
decade
um
and uh and i think uh all along that
curve you've got different personas that
are playing a role in in the build out
of this ecosystem